hey guys how's it going against recede
and this video has been very very
requested and I didn't even realize that
I haven't updated you guys on which
Apple watch I decided to keep there has
been quite the Apple watch dilemma going
on in my household it's really so stupid
I mean it's definitely the most first
world problem that you'll ever hear
about so long story short the Apple
watches that I ordered was the 38 gray
ceramic which was one of the brand-new
ones they recently launched and the 42
white ceramic which was the one that I
had intended on keeping ever since my
first Apple watch I have always had the
42 and for whatever reason I just
thought that's the way that the Apple
watches are supposed to fit I have very
small wrists and when I tried on that 38
millimeter one I was like this fits
perfect oh boy this is really nice
actually I mean do I need a bigger
screen does this look better on me but
the problem was I didn't necessarily
like the gray one I really like the
white watch face and I love this pink
band and I think this looks so good on
the white this is the look that I like I
mean good I love it I love the pink with
the white so it's having such a debate
and I was like I don't know what to do I
don't know which one I should keep I
think that the 38 fits me so much better
but I have all of these 42 millimeter
bands what do I do
it's such a stupid problem to have but
you know when your entire of life
basically revolves around your love of
Apple products these are the types of
problems that I have I mean I have
plenty of other ones but these are the
ones that I choose to share with you
here on YouTube so a few days after I
decided alright I know what I'm gonna do
I'm going to keep the 38 millimeter
white but I didn't have it and the
shipping was like six weeks out which I
thought was crazy so I ended up ordering
that one and then I was gonna return the
two that I already had and then I saw at
a local Apple Store I could pick it up
same day so I did I went picked up the
38 I had it all was well but for some
reason the one that I had just ordered
that said was going to ship in six weeks
it shipped that day and I'm freaking out
my credit card is like fraud fraud fraud
so that one shows up within a day so I
then have the
the Apple watches that I have to return
and I'm like this is absolutely insane
so the otter watches are returned I then
and back with my beautiful 38 ceramic
which is so great I love the fit I love
the pink band
I love the white face and love even the
red dot which uh stay tuned because I
have a video coming out very very
shortly to show you how to cover this
thing up even the red dot doesn't bother
me as much anymore mostly because I
can't really see it because when I'm
going like this I don't see it so the
red dot signifies that this is a
cellular Apple watch and if you guys
don't what that is
I mean clearly you've gotta know if
you're watching my channel because I've
talked about it so many times this but
what the heck was that that scared me so
bad my GoPro just turned off but that
happened as soon as I touched this and I
was like that's not a sound that my
watch is supposed to make anyway the red
signifies that it is a cellular Apple
watch which means you can make calls you
can send text messages if you don't have
your phone which is so awesome like
that's so great I can go walk the dog I
can still have my watch with me I can
make calls I can reply to text messages
I can still get Instagram notifications
right here on my wrist now in theory
this should have been a very very very
easy thing to set up some of my friends
had no problems at all but for the first
week or so there were some issues there
a bunch of complications but my
complications were not on the Apple side
they were on the carrier side for
whatever reason I was not able to add a
line and everything that could possibly
go wrong was going wrong and I was so
confused I probably spent maybe six
hours total on the phone with tech
support I mean there were times I was
basically just cleaning my house and I
had them on speakerphone and they would
come back and be like are you still
there I'm like yeah I'm still here the
kitchen's clean I've moved on to the
living room but throughout this whole
process I will say the people that I
talked to on the phone in tech support
and customer service were so nice like I
have never had such a good experience
like talking to customer support they're
asking me about my day what I plan on
doing for the weekend I felt like I had
made some new best friends and they kept
saying we're so sorry we don't know why
this is happening and this and that I
think it's because I've been such a
longtime customer did everything that I
had was like old line
and I'm grandfathered in for unlimited
data just it was pretty much the perfect
storm of disaster they could possibly
happen getting this to work but with all
that being said it now works which is
amazing I'm gonna try to call my sister
I'm putting this in airplane mode so you
guys will see that it work call Jana is
Eric College and she's definitely gonna
pick up because I never call anyone so
she's probably gonna think that it's an
emergency here we go here we go I think
it took a second to realize that it was
no longer on Wi-Fi and connected to my
phone hello it's not an emergency I know
I'm making a video about the Apple watch
smells like oh my god Jenna's definitely
gonna think something is wrong it's
working this is great yeah I was like
Jenna's definitely not think this is an
emergency because I never call and what
I do it's an emergency I am so sorry if
you had your watch on you would go no no
emergency okay well thanks for uh thanks
for answering I was gonna text you but
then I had already turned my phone on to
airplane mode I was like all right I
gotta just call I'm sorry
thanks for playing okay that's it bye I
didn't have any I know I'm making you
video like right now you're this is a
demo of the Apple watch making a phone
call really okay you call me okay I'll
call you answer on your watch calling
generic I'll get a drink are you on your
watch are you on your watch yeah that
actually sounds better than you did on
the phone okay bye Thanks
well that's that I mean it was a super
long story and a lot of dumb problems
and really you know it's just it's very
very silly and insignificant and really
just a dumb I just seen problems so feel
free to make fun of me all you want I'm
a
in front of myself my friends had made
fun of me but here we are I ended up
with a watch that I wanted and I'm
extremely very very happy with it so
thank you guys for your suggestions I
read through almost all of the comments
and so many of you guys really just seen
you clearly like the 38 millimeter so
get the 38 I just didn't even know that
the 42 was too big for my wrist I mean
it basically took up my entire wrist and
I didn't even realize it I mean like I
did but maybe I was in denial and I
cannot believe how soon it's gonna be
before the iPhone tennis here so prepare
yourself in the meantime if you guys
aren't already subscribed to my channel
feel free to do so just click Subscribe
and you hit that little Bell button so
you guys will get notifications when I
post the new video which is sometimes
frequent sometimes a little less
frequent but that's all I've got for you
today can guys help my current favorite
color is hints
[Music]